well join me to discuss all this is a
Republican strategist and former chair
of the anti-trump Republicans Liz mayor
the conservative talk radio host
sensation Ben Fergus I think he wrote
that and the CEO of outkick clay Travis
well welcome to all of you a Stella
panel to debate all things Trump who is
of course the elephant in the room so
Liz let me start with you Trump uh is
basically now calling for all Republican
debates to be cancelled without him
there's no point the Republican Party
should save their money invest it all in
going after Biden meanwhile the
president
is having a whole plan to try and keep
him on his feet um I've got to say from
this end of the pond this all looks a
bit ridiculous uh you got a guy facing a
100 criminal charges and they've got a
bloke in the office who can't barely see
or walk straight what is
happening it's pathetic um I I would
just like to say at this moment that I'm
British as well as American and I am
leaning really hard into being a
conservative which given how bad our
polling is should really tell you
something um yeah no it's pathetic we
have a nation of what 350 million people
and this is the best we can do um I'm
just lucky I live in a state that
nobody's going to be contesting so I can
write in whoever I want and feel good
about my vote but generally yeah it's a
complete disaster it's a complete
disaster Ben Ferguson it's a complete
disaster yeah I I wish you'd stop
showing those videos of Joe Biden
because you're about to get rid of the
candidate that I desperately want to run
any Republican against so if you'll stop
doing that and let's just say he's
brilliant let's say he's competent let's
say he is a vigorous young man just like
Ronald Reagan that would make my life a
lot easier but the reality is Democrats
right now put themselves in a corner if
you look at Joe Biden honestly right the
way that you just did you're you got to
be sitting there going what the hell are
we doing but they're stuck with him and
then you look at KLA Harris you say okay
well maybe KLA will calm down people
because they'll say hey if someone has
to take over at least they'll like the
VP the problem is her approval rating is
even worse than Joe Biden's right now
which is at Jimmy Carter levels so it's
a disaster for them as for the
Republicans look I think any Republican
Donald Trump de santis or somebody else
comes along I don't think it's gonna
happen based on what I saw at the
debates last night but if someone else
came along they all want to run against
Joe Biden because there's no way he can
campaign vigorously and I don't think
CO's going to save him from doing more
debates in the future I think this guy's
a train wreck and they know it but
talking of train wrecks Donald Trump who
is The Runaway favorite now to win
Republican nomination and wants all the
debates scraped and so on he is facing
nearly 100 criminal charges we are into
completely unprecedented territory here
where you could end up with the
Republican nominee being convicted of
some of these charges before an election
potentially even sent to a prison cell
which I suspect would increase his poll
numbers like everything else has been
done legally to him
but how can that be right for America to
have a president sitting in cell block
AG people aren't worried about it I mean
that's the reality they're not worried
the Republican party has made it clear
they're not worried as an American no
I'm not either because I think that
these charges and if you look at them
they're pretty ridiculous and egregious
you made up charges in Georgia when the
statute of limitations had already run
out for goodness sakes and when you
fight these I don't worry about it and I
think the the American people showing
that they still support him the
Republican primary he's got a 40-point
lead combine everyone else's poll
numbers they don't even add up to even
anywhere close to where Donald Trump is
pulling by himself right now so that's
how little Republicans care about this
they know it's a Witch Hunt they know
it's going after your political opponent
in the way they do the Banana Republic
and the poll numbers show that the
majority of Americans that Republicans
are smart enough to understand this is
political crap it's Banana Republic crap
it's what they do in Russia and China
and they're not worried about it that's
why he's still pulling where he is all
right Klay Travis you like the santis
I've interviewed Ronda santis he's an
impressive character he gets stuff done
as his big Mantra he's on a very good
job as governor of Florida no doubt
about it it seems to me Des San he was I
thought he was the best on the debate
stage last night actually for what is
worth and let's take a little look at
danan action last
night I think we have it uh the former
president um you know he's missing an
action tonight he's had a lot to say
about that he should be here explaining
his comments to try to say that pro-life
protections are somehow a terrible thing
you know the problem Clay is is Right
Trump should be there and I know Chris
Christie called him Donald Duck and
that's fine we all have a good laugh but
if you're Donald Trump you think why why
do I have to bother I'm so far ahead of
all of these people why do I have to
bother turning out to any debate I've
got this in the bag he's right isn't
he well yeah he's right right now so far
and that's why the biggest question
coming out of this debate uh and thanks
for having on Pierce by the way is
everybody else needs to drop out of the
race but potentially Ronda santis and
Nikki Haley they need to be able to
fight it out figure out who is the
unquestioned number two and then they
need to have a head-to-head with uh with
Donald Trump and remember as crazy as
the Democrat process was in 2020 what
did they do Joe Biden got smoked in Iowa
he got crushed in New Hampshire he left
before the vote was even taken in New
Hampshire I think he finished fifth and
sixth and then what happened James kurn
congressman from South Carolina said all
that matters is beating Donald Trump Joe
Biden is the choice he's our guy and it
was over the Democrats said we're going
to pick the guy that we believe is the
most electable it's old boring plotting
dementia Joe they may have gotten lucky
with coid happening honestly because
that allowed them to keep Joe Biden in
the basement and not get out and
everybody could see how physically frail
and mentally diminished he was but they
made the decision he's the guy that's
most likely to win think about this
Pierce Ronda santis or Nikki Haley
running against Joe Biden would be a
unmitigated disaster for Democrats and I
think what's changed here is a lot of
Republicans are so convinced that Joe
Biden is going to lose that they aren't
even focused on the electability angle
as much as as they can be remember Trump
has half of the electorate right now the
other half is for somebody else right
here the problem I think for your guy
Dan santis is I think it's a Charisma
issue issue that most people think he's
competent you know he's done a good job
blah blah blah he just doesn't have
anywhere near Trump's Charisma funny
enough the one with all the Charisma on
the stage last night is vivec ramaswami
if you could inject that Charisma into
DeSantis with his experience as governor
and success you probably have a very
very very compelling cand let's take a
look at vi
vi transgenderism especially in kids is
a mental health disorder we have to
acknowledge the truth of that for what
it is typically on parental rights in
school parents have the right to know
the very people who say that this
increases the risk of suicide are also
the ones saying that parents don't have
the right to know about that increased
risk of suicide and I'm sorry it is not
compassionate to affirm a kid's
confusion that is not compassion that is
cruelty so I will ban genital mutilation
or chemical castion under the AG of so I
also want to play now the Christy gag
about Donald Duck was funny let's take a
look at this and I want to look at that
camera right now and tell you Donald I
know you're watching you can't help
yourself I know you're watching okay and
you're not here tonight not because of
polls and not because of your
indictments you're not here tonight
because you're afraid of being on the
stage and defending your record you're
ducking these things and let me tell you
what's going to happen you keep doing
that no one up here is going to call you
Donald Trump anymore we're going to call
you Donald Duck all right now you see
he's quite funny Christie and he's a bit
of an old Bruiser I like him I've known
him a long time and that was a funny gag
if you could buy his humor and kind of
pugnacious Style with V's energy and
dynamism and Charisma uh with the
competence of Dan santis you've got a
very very strong candidate the problem
is none of them have the other two
components and Trump in his own way love
him hate him think he's the worst thing
ever all the greatest things the slice
bread he has it all and that's why at
the moment he's steaming ahead yes I
would can I just jump here and make a
couple of points first of all I think
it's worth noting when you take a look
at a lot of these post- debate polls
though what you say about Vic sounds
like it's right but when you look at how
voters are actually responding he's
actually coming off very very negatively
to quite a lot of Republican primary
voters so I'm not sure that you're quite
right about his Charisma I agree with
you that Ronda santz does need some sort
of Charisma injection for sure um I'm
not sure that him necessarily borrowing
from Chris Christie is the best move
though I actually thought Donald Duck
line fell a little bit flat I thought it
was a little obvious I didn't find it
particularly humorous um I also do think
that DeSantis and Christie need to quit
saying that Trump needs to show up at
these debates because one of the really
interesting things and we saw this in
2016 also when Trump skips debates other
people move up and his floor the
absolute minimum that he's gonna get
actually goes down that happened after
the last debate I bet it's gonna happen
after this debate let me all right let
let me bring in Ben on that that does
matter I agree with you Ben here's this
issue seems to me Trump could well run
away with this Republican nomination it
looks like he might but if he does a lot
of independent have a problem with Trump
and you've got to win with the
independence to become president and it
may be that if Biden insists on running
that the only way the Democrats win that
next election is if Trump is the
opponent because the anti-trump vote
comes out as you know and The
Independents don't like him and they
won't like all the legal stuff that
actually Trump May steamroll everyone to
get my nomination for the Republican
party and then actually lose again yeah
look I I think that there's two things
here with trump it depends on if he can
be a disciplined politician in a general
election and you'll probably laugh at
the idea of him being disciplined but
look he's been pretty smart recently and
I think he's starting to understand that
he's got to be smart about how he talks
for the same reason that you just said
if he talks about the here and now and
he doesn't take those loaded questions
about the past and retiga the past and
he's talks about gas prices and interest
rates and the economy and securing the
border and building the wall he will
destroy Joe Biden if he is undisciplined
and he goes back and tries to litigate
the past and say I won the last election
he gets bogged down in that you're right
there's a chance that Joe Biden could
win but Joe Biden will not win because
he has the best set of plans for this
country or ideas he is a disaster a
stumbling bubling falling down disaster
he would win because he's not Donald
Trump I want to end by getting all of
you he also win well hang on I've run
I've run out of time here's what I want
to ask all of you and I need straight
answers I want to have the two names for
the two people that will face off in
this presidential race next year I I
want to have a name of a winner as well
so Liz you go
first that's tough to say it's really
tough to say right now the polling does
suggest it's going to be Biden and Trump
but I have this sneaking suspicion that
somehow it could end up being somebody
like Brian Kemp versus Gavin Newsome or
JB pritzer because I think both of these
guys are so old and decra and you can't
name you can't name
might die I need two names and a winner
go on please okay well let's go with
Nome and Kemp and I think in that uh
contest I think Kemp dust Sno him and
I'm a happy camper okay Ben I'm just
gonna go back to reality I'll bet you
seats at Wimbledon because it's on my
bucket list Piers it's gonna be Trump
and Biden and no one else matters and
who wins I think Donald Trump I think
Joe Biden and what you showed earlier is
going to be what you're going to see for
next year and a half no doubt about that
and by the way there will be far more
added to the greatest hits too clay yeah
two names and a winner all right I'll
give you a fun one I'll give you a fun
one pierce I think it's going to be
Donald Trump I think the Democrats are
going to end up drafting Michelle Obama
wow and I think it's going to be Trump
versus Michelle Obama and Michelle Obama
finds her way into the White House she
would be she would she would be amazing
but I the Democrat debates get ready
she'll come in at the convention I I I
actually clay and I agree on
this I think it's I think she would be
great I actually think she was I prefer
I think Biden is going to get so much
worse physically that it's going to be
impossible and I think M they'll have to
find somebody new Michelle Obama would
be formidable I think a really good
candidate I just don't think she'll ever
do it but we got to leave it there we'll
find out thank you to my pack I
appreciate
it